and is there something
beyond cellular so you mentioned
lifestyle
interventions or changes as a way to uh
or like be able to prescribe changes in
life style
like what what about organs what about
like
the function of the body as a whole yeah
absolutely so basically
when you go to your doctor they always
measure you know your pulse they always
measure your height those measure your
weight
your you know your bmis basically these
are just very basic variables
but with digital devices nowadays you
can start measuring hundreds of
variables for every individual
you can basically also phenotype
cognitively
through tests alzheimer's patients
there are cognitive tests that you can
imagine that you that you typically do
for uh cognitive decline this mini
mental
you know observations that that you have
specific questions too
you can think of sort of enlarging the
set of cognitive tests
so in the mouse for example you do
experiments for how do they get out of
mazes
how do they find food whether they
recall a fear
whether they shake in a new environment
and so forth
in the human you can have much much
richer phenotypes where you can
basically say
not just imaging at the you know
organ level but and and all kinds of
other activities at the organ level
but you can also do at the organism
level
you can do behavioral tests and how did
they do on empathy
how did they do on memory how did they
do on
long-term memory versus short-term
memory and so forth i love how you're
calling that phenotype
i guess it is it is but like your
behavior patterns that might change over
over uh over a period of a life it's
yeah your ability to remember things
your ability to be
yeah empathetic or emotionally your
intelligence
perhaps even yeah but intelligence has
hundreds of variables you can be your
math intelligence your literary
intelligence your puzzle solving
intelligence your logic it could be like
hundreds of things
and all of that is it's we were able to
measure that better and better
and all that could be connected to the
entire pipeline we used to think of each
of these as a single variable like
intelligence i mean that's ridiculous
it's basically dozens of different genes
that are controlling every single
variable you can basically think of you
know imagine us in a video game where
every one of us has
measures of you know strength stamina
you know energy left and so forth
but you could click on each of those
like five bars that are just the main
bars and
each of those will just give you then
hundreds of bars yeah and you can
basically say okay great for my
you know machine learning task i want
someone who
i'm a human who has these particular
forms of intelligence
i require now these you know 20
different things
and then you can combine those things
and then relate them
to of course performance in a particular
task but you can also relate them to
genetic variation that might be
affecting
different parts of the brain for example
your frontal cortex versus your temporal
cortex versus your visual
cortex and so forth so genetic variation
that affects expression of genes in
different parts of your brain
can basically affect your you know music
ability your auditory ability your smell
your you know just dozens of different
phenotypes
can be broken down into you know
hundreds of cognitive variables
and then relate each of those to
thousands of genes that are associated
with them
so somebody who loves rpgs role-playing
games
there's uh there's too few variables
that we can control so i'm excited
if we're in fact living in a simulation
and this is a video game
i'm excited by the quality of of the
video game the
the the the game designer did a hell of
a good job so
we're impressed oh i don't know the
sunset last night was a little
unrealistic
yeah yeah the graphics exactly come on
nvidia
you